وكما نعلم، فإن عدد القتلى آخذ في الارتفاع
بشكل مطرد، حيث تجاوز بالفعل 1900
شخص قتلوا في غزة بسبب الغارات الجوية الإسرائيلية
مع آلاف آخرين من الجرحى حتى
الآن. نعم، يعتبر النزوح قضية شائكة بالنسبة
للعديد من الفلسطينيين الذين كانوا في غزة فقط
لأنهم نزحوا منذ عقود عديدة،
لذا فإن  أُمر الفلسطينيون بالمغادرة باتجاه
الجنوب ولكننا نسمع الآن تقارير تفيد
بأن الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم تعرضوا
للضربات، فماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا أكثر عن
ذلك، دعنا نصحح هذا
البيان المؤلم الذي تم تحديثه من
وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية داخل غزة يوم الجمعة، حيث
يقولون إن عائلات بأكملها كانت  تم
استهدافهم بغارات جوية في منتصف
الشارع أثناء محاولتهم
الفرار، كما تم
استهداف ثلاث
سيارات إسعاف على الأقل وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة الفلسطينية في غزة في
غارة جوية أمس، كل هذا بينما كان
المدنيون يحاولون الهرب.  اخلاء حسب
أمر أه الجيش الإسرائيلي
المتجه من شمال غزة إلى الجنوب
ولدينا مقطع فيديو
أصدرته وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية
يحذر مشاهدينا أنه أمر
مؤلم ومصور ألقِ نظرة
[موسيقى]
الآن بالطبع مايكل  كما نعلم،
تقول قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية إنها
تستهدف أهدافًا تابعة لحماس في غزة، لكن نظرًا لأن
هذا قطاع من الأرض مكتظ بالسكان يبلغ
حجمه ضعف مساحة
واشنطن العاصمة فقط لوضعه على نطاق واسع
في ظل الحصار الذي
يخضع له حاليًا  الحصار أيضًا يعني عدم وجود طعام
أو ماء أو كهرباء في
المستشفيات التي تعتمد على بضع
ساعات فقط من الكهرباء كل يوم في هذه
المرحلة، لذا بالطبع فإن
الخسائر الإنسانية تتزايد
يومًا بعد يوم ومن المتوقع أن هذا  سوف
يزداد الأمر سوءًا مايكل حقًا،
شكرًا NADA على تقريرك عن NADA bash
هناك في
لندن